[Music]
when it went public this week the
electric truck makerian vaulted past
ford and general motors to become the
second most valuable automaker in
america while some drivers are ready to
go electric they still want to hang on
to their classic cars and that's where
one mechanic in london is ready to help
ian lee has the story
on the surface they look like any
classic cars you can't see what makes
them special
and you can't hear it either smooth and
quiet is what electricity does perfectly
but peek under the hood and you can see
how matthew quitter converts classic
cars into electric rides at his london
base garage we have customers from all
over the world converting gas guzzlers
helps the environment especially since
more than a million cars in the uk end
up on the scrap heap every year
scrapping cars is not a good thing to do
you know it's sort of fairly well known
now that half of a car's
lifetime co2 output is during
manufacture we took a ride in his
electric 1953 morris minor you become
slightly more aware of how
stinky a lot of other cars are
gearheads might find his conversions
sacrilege is there one car you wouldn't
convert yeah there's quite a few
we had a customer inquirer about
converting aston martin db4gt zagato
which is nuts just nuts
but rest assured for the converted the
charm remains
it's just falling off
a little bit of a classic car exactly
guy wilner didn't have a problem
swapping motors in his 1969 land rover
series 2a the land rover engine is
nothing really very exciting to me
what's exciting is the gearbox the
four-wheel drive the electric touch
didn't disappoint oh it's brilliant fun
it's brilliant fun it's absolutely
hilarious i mean it's a hilarious car
converting a classic can set you back at
least 30 grand but for matthew it's not
just about the money once they get in
the car and it's converted you get big
ev grin and that's it they're never
going back
leaving gas in the rearview mirror as
they drive their converted classics into
the 21st century
for cbs saturday morning ian lee london